there are many miles to drive and many
heavy loads to lift before we can end
the petrol age and the burning of fossil
fuels which causes climate change
lord banford the chairman of the british
heavy vehicle maker jcb believes he's
found what could be the most important
invention of the 21st century not
electricity not fuel cells but the
internal combustion of hydrogen one of
the basic components of water h2o
we started with batteries and could we
not have batteries across our range of
machines
and we found for various reasons the
batteries didn't work
so we had to look at an alternative and
the alternative was was a fuel cell
which was powered by hydrogen
the jcb team found that batteries were
too heavy and fuel cells too complex and
expensive they also needed plug-in
points the technology for internal
combustion engines is better known
adapted this time for hydrogen we
understand batteries but we also stand
understand the limitations of both both
the product and the infrastructure
we've experimented with fuel cells and
we realize that fuel cells have
limitations i think our customers always
challenge us to produce machines that
aren't too complicated aren't too
expensive for the market they serve
and this hydrogen combustion solution is
just perfect for that
but hydrogen shares a problem with
electricity it'll only help save the
planet if it is generated without
burning fossil fuels
at the moment around 95 of the hydrogen
created for use in the uk
is generated from fossil fuels
where hydrogen has got a role to play is
where the battery
simply doesn't give us the functionality
needed for longer distance travel or
movement of heavier things
so could hydrogen be used to power
lighter vehicles such as the family
runabout
fiona spouse thinks so she and her
husband have raised five million pounds
through crowdfunding to build these
prototypes in wales
i think it's going to be very good for
the corner cases where batteries won't
work so if you lived i don't know in a
third floor flat
in a town
it's going to be pretty hard work trying
to
recharge a battery electric car hydrogen
is potentially portable through pipes
compressed in canisters and in liquid
form at super low temperatures fiona has
a dream
i'm thinking the full court of the
future should have hydrogen and
electricity
uh replacing diesel and
and petrol and i think we will see that
but at present there are pitifully few
hydrogen stations in the uk just 14
across the whole country
the private hydrogen car market still
has much further to go